hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with the Libertarian
Party candidate for president governor
gary johnson former two-term republican
governor of new mexico thanks for
talking with us Nick it's great to be
talking with you you were a Republican
but you you're much better now talk
about what prompted the shift from a
Republican affiliation to libertarian
and what did what it why is it better to
be a libertarian well first of all
working within the Republican Party
trying to give a voice to what I think
were the majority of Republicans coming
over the Libertarian Party didn't have
to change a thing you know we're now in
the thick of the presidential campaign
season and neither Obama nor Mitt Romney
have really talked about where they're
going to be cutting spending this is a
linchpin of your campaign how much do we
have to cut them where's it going to
come from in a Gary Johnson presence
well I am promising to submit a balanced
budget to Congress in the year 2013 and
that is a forty three percent reduction
in spending representing 1.4 trillion
dollars so with that to just cut across
the board or are there just certain
things that you say okay this is done
we're not the government shouldn't be
doing this well yes there it is across
the board there are certain things also
that the government shouldn't be doing
at all but I think most important is is
pointing out pointing to the big ticket
items like Medicaid Medicare military
spending I'm going to propose a forty
three percent reduction in military
spending which takes us back to the year
two thousand three when it comes to
funding levels wouldn't that just leave
us open to China to terrorists to Canada
taking over I mean I mean to say that
we're going back to two thousand three
levels of defense spending I would I
would have to say that we can and will
provide a strong national defense for
this country defense being the operative
word as opposed to offense and as
opposed to nation building look we're
building roads
schools bridges highways and hospitals
half a world away and don't we have
those same needs here in this country
what about Medicaid Medicaid as the
country's health plan for the poor its
split between the federal government and
states so you're just saying poor people
you're on your own so as governor of New
Mexico I oversaw the reform of Medicaid
we took it from health care to the poor
we took it from a fee-for-service model
to a managed care model so we bet with
set up better healthcare networks and we
saved hundreds of millions of dollars
Nick at the time I believe that if the
federal government would have blocked
granted the state of New Mexico
forty-three percent less money for
Medicaid done away with all the strings
and the mandates associated on the
delivery of healthcare to the poor that
I could have effectively overseen the
delivery of healthcare to the poor no
strings no mandates fixed amount of
money I think the same template needs to
apply to Medicare health care for those
over 65 federal government Block Grant
the states federal government get out of
the business of health care delivery
completely and leave it up to 50
laboratories of innovation and best
practice and I think that's exactly what
you'll have fabulous success that will
get emulated by other states horrible
failure that will get avoided for the
same reasons one of the goals of your
candidacy is to make sure that you get
on the debate stage with Mitt Romney and
with Barack Obama what what has to
happen for that to happen and what are
you doing to make that well right right
now I need to be in the polls that
determine who gets in the debates now in
the polls that I'm in I'm at a low of
six percent I'm at a high of fifteen
percent so that's saying likely voters
when they're saying hey who you going to
vote for for president Gary Johnson
shown up somewhere between six to six
percent and 15 when my name is included
so right now we're asking everybody I'm
asking everybody that would be watching
this get online Gary Johnson 2012 and
and we have a list of the phone numbers
of all the polling organizations just
ask the polling organizations to include
my name in the polls you have a
fascinating
a succinct campaign slogan right now
which revolves around the idea of saying
vote libertarian just this one time and
I'm mangling it but what's the thinking
behind that and what do you what are you
hoping to work out that that there are a
lot more people in this country that
describe themselves as libertarian than
vote libertarian so what we're trying to
tie into here is just that notion look
you are a libertarian you're a
libertarian so how about voting that way
and by libertarian you mean fiscally
conservative socially liberal speaking
with a broad brush stroke yeah we're
Fisk that we are fiscally responsible
and that we actually care about really
care about civil liberties and the
erosion of those civil liberties so yeah
you're a libertarian but how about just
this one time voting that way and what
will that accomplish me being in the
White House and I'm gonna argue actually
addressing the problems that we have in
this country yeah okay well governor
gary johnson thank you very much the
Libertarian Party candidate for
president in 2012 thanks for talking
with reason to go thank you very much
for reason TV I'm Nick Gillespie